here on the way of an insulin Uganda
Africa some banded mongooses have
discovered a termite swarm they swarm on
the swarm and then predator turns prey
when the mongooses nemesis the marabou
stork appears while the mongooses are
busy with the termites the marabou
storks have their sights set on the
mongoose babies
[Music]
so Pakistan's fast trying to fight off
the storks these mongooses are no
pushover
they're famous for fighting and killing
snakes including Cobras so it's not
surprising naked flight offs of marabou
storks even though these birds are 5
feet tall and have wing spans of eight
and a half feet the mongooses are barely
pushing two feet tail included how long
and these scrappy little fighters told
off the largest storks in the world
the mother Mongoose after seven pups
have now taken refuge in this stack of
fishing boats the marabou stork swoops
in still looking to snatch a young one
one of the pops is ventured outside the
boats
dad makes the safe just in time then he
does his best to distract the big birds
but the storks seem to be getting
cranked they came for a pup and they
won't get an eye the Mongoose is
abandoned and look for more secure
turf soon some errands find a new home
but where there are Mongoose pops there
will soon be four raesha storks and the
battle is on a third time
[Music]
one pump gets separated and just like
that a stork picks him off
despite the packs best effort the storks
win this death and moms brood numbers
only six